looming in the West Hall South Hall of
III is a statue I'm told of five
badasses tempting you to come in and
play battleborn battleborn is here Randy
Pitchford president CEO of gearbox is
here and if III is on Randy Osborne is
here in a big way I we're here at e3 e3
isn't a big way there's so many awesome
games here already and it's like just
getting started you know I can't believe
how like what the what position were in
as an industry right now um it is no
better time to be a gamer to dive in the
next gen appear if you're already here
you can feel it you're not on the next
gen yet you need to be a student on here
because there's so much awesome vrda are
dominant is so much cool stuff at the
booth the 2k has for us at battle born
it's unreal it's like the biggest booth
like it just just destroys the stuff we
did for borderlands like it doesn't say
I can't believe how much to caves behind
the game I'm just like oh my god this is
great I hope people like the game o
people like this I mean yeah but people
are getting to get a look at it now yeah
we available we got playable playable at
people are playing right now go over
there barring the game it's easier uh so
I can I is very important question is
the mushroom samurai badass playable uh
I believe Miko is one of the play i yes
i'm pretty sure Miko's playable I know
yumiko we want to find the mushroom
Randy you know we're shipping the game
it's it's this crazy hero super shooter
we're shipping the game with 25 playable
characters Wow we have 10 playable on
the show floor today okay but 20 in a
borderland ship we had four playable
characters yeah and then we added a
couple as DLC but we're shipping the
game with 25 playable characters in each
character we've invested about four
times as much in each character as we
did for the border lands characters
that's across the board that's in
voiceover and how many like how much
dialogue they have that's in bones for
animation that's in fidelity of the
materials and how many you know how much
detail we build these guys out of how
many polygons of characters on every
aspect of these characters about four
times the investment does the bone
budget get more expensive when you have
4i all right so yeah so right now you're
looking at a red
who's this [ __ ] in which basically and
she is super wicked one of her special
abilities allows her to create this
column of dark matter and dark energy
that just rips guys apart dark magic I
love her ND I in fact I rendy is one of
the most in my opinion one of the most
powerful assassins in the game just
really good at a throughput and doing a
lot of damage to groups of enemies good
at AOE this is cal Tereus now these guys
are all battleborn all these characters
are our battle born and Cal Darius is
one of the battle born he's just this
awesome kind of Gundam guy he's got jet
packs again you can zip around with
battle roar as the name for them in
addition to just being the name of the
game yeah we call them battle born there
there each members of factions that are
around the last star and the last star
in the entire universe is where it's all
going to go down we know that eventually
all the stars will burn out and it ran
some point in the future real dark at
some point the whole universe will be
dark at some points to everybody three
but but before that moment there's going
to be one star left in every species
that has the ability to travel the Stars
will end up there and they're all going
to disagree right some factions will
think they need to protect that star
others will want to study it and to
understand what makes it work maybe to
keep it alive long or maybe to create
other stars some can't wait for the end
they're almost like religious fanatics
they can't wait for it all to be over
all the thinking uh they can you know
maybe maybe they believe there's going
to be some some future who knows what
the mushroom men believe right but but
in the story of battle born all these
opposing factions realize they have to
come together to fight against the real
madness and that's the what's destroying
the universe you see we know today the
universe is being torn apart being
accelerated and everything's spreading
apart faster than it should and it's
dark matter and dark energy that's
behind that so our crazy little fiction
we've invented personifies that we've
created this entity called the ver el c
which are like the bad guys that are
tearing the universe apart and you have
to deal with we gotta take care they've
got to become one of the battleborn now
thanks yeah go ahead you talked about
the battleborn is sort of being
potentially antagonistic towards each
other that's your maybe your competitive
multiplayer sort
side of it yeah you're the factions are
at war yeah they all have to come
together to deal with this greater
struggle but what we're seeing now is
the co-operative side yeah so battleborn
actually has several game modes you can
play a campaign you can play a totally
solo so it's a single player campaign or
you can play cooperatively and up to
five people can play together so it's
it's it's pretty full featured in that
regard and there is a PvP mode a
full-fledged I'm hoping people really
like it and enjoy the competitive mode
because i'd love to see i'd love to see
us investing more of the esports kind of
stuff with this game we're having fun
playing competitive every day here at e3
people are playing the campaign there
it's broken into a series of chapters
uh-huh so each scenario you can consume
and it's in a scenario of gameplay a
little session of gameplay and you'll
level up your hero you'll earn gear and
loot and you'll deal with bad guys in
badasses and it's a lot of fun to play
cooperatively it's also a lot of fun to
play alone because it gives you kind of
more time to check out the environments
which are just beautiful Scott cast her
the art director and his team have just
done an incredible job rendering this
environment and you know Scott was the
character designer for borderlands so
we've really just taken the shackles off
of him yeah you sure yet some money no
not yet some creative looking characters
in Borderlands but I think battleborn
you guys have definitely taken it to a
new level sort of also just the sheer
diversity of characters you have any
look at sort of art for the game reveals
any number of wildly different looking
heroes and that's driven not merely by
the art direction but also by the game
design and Randy varnel who's just an
awesome designer he was the design
producer Borderlands 2 just an
incredible talented guy super passionate
about the game he's been working hand in
hand with the engineering team the
creature team from Borderlands that did
all the enemies is on on battleborn and
our Scott Custer and his art team and
these guys have all been working
together to make this just incredible
experience that I'm in love with I
remember when I first talked to Scott
and Randy about about doing this game
and the idea of it and here we are we're
playing it it's incredible and when you
talk about play the plate experience of
play here uh in Borderlands you know its
first person shooting action it's I you
know your sort of general
a ground-based I mean there's some
jumping there's some mild platforming in
the environments but when you look at
the battleborn characters you got to
imagine that sort of being nimble moving
around the environment and also having
specific powers that feed into that is a
lot more of a part of battle born than
it was Borderlands and so I mean is that
true is this really depends on the
actual experience of playing the only
depends on the character part of the
fantasy we have in creating battle born
is to make sure that all of our
different arch types all the different
kinds of characters we like to play as
in first-person shooter represented in
some way so yeah you'll find super
nimble characters like thorn you can
leap across incredibly far distances or
or you'll find these like stout like
boulders like this this really stout
dwarf guy who's just super tough and he
wields an axe and he's got a kilt and in
fact from certain camera angles when
this kilt flies up we actually do the
blurry thing oh let's meet dwarven
obscure tonight no it's it's it's only
only in battle born there's others
there's characters with stealth
abilities there's character like super
tanks like Montana is just massive so
he's a slow and lumbering all it is like
this big yes but his head is in
proportion with his feet if you look
close that's alright just at least a
rhyme and reason in the world but but
these guys there's a spectrum so so
really we're trying to think of if you
have a certain style of play carrot of
character that you like to play in a
first-person shooter you can find
something for you in battle born it's
for every every badass is represented
every and and and it's just um it's it's
cool for me because I like I'm a snack
boxer I like sampling different
characters so Mac boxers a type as well
you guys yeah I like sampling all the
different characters but you know it's
weird sometimes I'll get into one and I
just and I'll just stick with that for a
while trying to master it and one of the
other things that's cool that we learn
from Borderlands you know to feel the
full potential of a character you have
to invest at least 35 40 hours yeah to
feel the full pretension we wanted to
feel these characters in more accessible
gaming sessions we want gamers that that
like to have fun playing with their
friends for short periods of time to be
able to get the full experience of
character so in the course of a scenario
or in a story chapter you'll be able to
get the full growth potential of that
character so if you want to try
thorn for example the elephant Archer
and you want to feel what her full
capabilities get multi shot arrows be
able to create like poison AOE blasts
and all the cool stuff she can do you
can fuel her full-grown tree in a single
scenario and then the next scenario you
play the next chapter you play you can
try one of the other characters like
Montana and even within the character
there are a stratus and that's a rendi
ya go in the character in games of this
ill tends to be a certain amount of
branching pathways you know if you have
a certain character to play over the
course of one match you play the second
match with that character you could
expect them in a real different way yeah
just in the scenario itself we have a
helix system which through a series of
binary choices every time you level up
you can do this skill or that skill this
skill or that skill and through that
series of binary choices you have
radically different ways that you can
build each character thousands of
combinations per character just in the
seas Randy this game sounds like a
balancing nightmare how do you guys be
here at all of these is faster it's a
freaking disaster we are playtesting at
every day care box and each week there's
like a new meta about which because you
know we're constantly like and what's
also cool is we have a focus test group
in fact we have hundreds of people that
are a part of our focus test group that
come into gear box and play the game
with us if you happen to live in the
dallas area let go to the gearbox
website you could sign up and if you're
lucky you might get chosen to play the
game with us and I hope and I and I'm
pretty sure we're going to be able to do
it we're going to do a beta later and
that'll get more people involved in the
combination of our crazy incessant
playtesting internally our focus test
group playing with us every single day
and in the beta that will unlock
hopefully will be pretty well balanced
by the time we launch but you know if
you know like all the support we did for
Borderlands you can expect us to
continue to support the game after we
launch and I think that's part of the
fun certainly Borderlands like a modern
standard for DLC support in terms of the
amount of stuff you guys put in and but
not just DLC to like we've we've done a
host of updates and we're still tweaking
on the drop rate balance in fact just
just a last month we did a run of each
week doing different drop rate changes
for legendary drops in Borderlands 2 and
Borderlands the pre-sequel and we've
updated that I still give out shift
codes if you follow me on twitter which
is at do
magic I give out content I give out free
stuff I can attest this is true every so
often your tweets are just a jibber
jabber of numbers and letters and I
can't wait to do it for battleborn we've
got so much more stuff that the outside
of these simple scenarios where you can
build your character completely within
just a short session we have a very
large metagame so there's a hobby grade
experience there you'll be getting loot
you'll be finding gear and you'll outfit
your character with gear and you modify
your gear set up in between matches then
you're directing character progression
yes in addition to be like in match
progressed correct that's correct
there's a broader progression for each
character that you collect there's also
a broader collection for your profile
for you yourself the player will rank up
and you'll earn benefits from ranking up
all right so Randy who's your flavor the
flavor of the day as you give me oh man
okay um I've been playing oh that's a
tough one I've been playing a rendi a
lots on the forearm Nash yeah i love i
love Randy um I tend to go back to
Montana one of the augments one of the
helix choices in the middle lets you
choose between fire and ice so like half
the time i'll pick fire which does a lot
more damage as a dot on the enemy and a
light them up on fire your barrel of
that minigun heats up and just lights on
fire and it's just so awesome to burn
guys down but then the other option is I
swear you can freeze enemies slow them
down cool everything off thats awesome
to Montana is just one of the standbys
and what's funny about Montana he was
originally in a furious 40 which just
completely got converted into a totally
different thing so it's kind of exposes
our evolutionary process and doubling
down on this game design that we've
evolved kind of echoes of mr. torgue in
Montana is a little bit of totally in
terms of his stature yeah yeah and yeah
I'll tell you also oscar mike is a lot
of fun to play he's just the classic you
know if you like Halo and like Space
Marines he is the classic space marine
if you are if you played halo and that
feels good to you you can pick Oscar
Mike and you'll know exactly what to do
and you feel exactly at home and he is
super fun to play because he's just that
classic you know standard archetype that
we've all played a million times and
he's their forces when he's right in
there amidst the mushroom people and the
four-armed windows
because actually a healer and but he's
pretty powerful to you can actually take
his mushroom head off and throw it into
the world and it creates this healing
mushroom cloud around yeah okay you just
takes his head off I say he I actually
don't think Miko has a gender gender
it's not neither he nor get some weird
species that is that can reproduce what
themselves i don't know i don't know how
many guys had some interesting
brainstorming sessions when it came to
coming up with some characters mego has
no gender and there's plenty on Phoebe's
awesome too i've been playing Phoebe a
lot she she's part of the LLC so she's
kind of this Victorian steampunk lookin
girl and she she summons these foils
which are swords and she creates these
magic swords and summons them and she
can have them rain down on enemies and
she's a lot of fun now with magic swords
you know Rick I'm not time when I talked
to Randy varnel one of the designers he
reminds us of like back Americans he
still has his Star Wars like Darth Vader
collectors case that you put all the
action figures in he's like this is like
the video game version of that like a
collector's case that you put all your
character yet all your action figures
yeah so you guys were saying you have
ten characters here playable aiming for
25 total we will ship with 25 you're
gonna ship with 20 blue that's crazy
that's a lot you think about that you
know when we sold the characters as DLC
we ship for in Borderlands we sold those
characters as DLC the publisher marked
them at ten bucks apiece we're including
25 characters that are all more
investment that we've ever made the
character at ship it's just unbelievable
how much content we're putting it and
it's only because we were so successful
Borderlands that we can invest so much
in this game well you guys had great
success with borderlands and here's
wishing you success with battle or so I
hope people like it cuz we're going nuts
we were really trying something that no
one's ever tried before so I hope people
really enjoy it well thanks for coming
on stage and talking battleborn folks if
you're here III go ahead and check it
out in the south hall
you